perroquet sur lisa plus près j'ai sangloté
ours de zoo iran ou attaché
nous partons dans la rue nous sommes ici depuis longtemps quelque chose
ne sont pas sortis ne sont pas partis, nous semblions savoir
route de ceux qui sont partis plus tôt nous partons et
il y aurait des fils qui traînent
même le film n'est plus la tâche principale
avons-nous compris que nous devions aller très
rapide
Je lui montrerai la valve et la femelle lion fout le camp d'ici
des pailles de téléphone étourdissent notre troublé
dans cette maison, en général, tout ce qui reste
nous tout ce que nous pouvions amasser, mais cela
photo d'il y a une semaine peut-être
aujourd'hui il n'y est plus du tout.
assis au sous-sol qu'est-ce que ça fait de tout
vole juste dans notre maison et
ont essayé de comprendre par eux-mêmes pourquoi tout le monde
c'est là qu'il vole jusqu'à chez nous mais pas le mari
est sorti presque puis avec le temps quand
il y avait une opportunité de sortir nous avons vu
que toute la ville est arrosée juste
Eh bien, ce n'est pas notre maison juste arrosée
quoi de suite et en plus comprendre
avions mais c'est le pire
parce qu'il
quand de lui la destruction comme nous l'avons déjà
on y voit le bien le plus grave
toute notre maison, il s'est assis au sous-sol sur notre
territoires
j'étais mort
les 8 dernières années dans la ville tout allait bien
réparé sain et
écoles-maternelles reconstruites
infrastructure achetée neuve
transport en commun ville active
développé un
Maintenant, quel genre de guerre cela peut-il être
tout est détruit je méprise
Le peuple russe méprise Poutine et laisse
ils disent ça
la russie contre la guerre est une bouche ordinaire
contre la guerre et tout est une décision d'un seul
mec je ne crois pas en cette décision
chacun d'eux et
abandonner aux mains de chacun d'eux maintenant
les avions volent et détruisent bien notre ville
il a ensuite été détruit par l'écoutille passée
le chemin et le soleil se refroidissent ont tué d'une part
le prendre par demi a commencé pire